>> GOOD AFTERNOON, EVERYONE.
MY NAME IS ROSLYN ENCINA, THE
CHIEF COMMUNICATIONS OFFICER FOR
THE LIBRARY. WELCOME TO THE
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS TODAY. WE'RE
EXCITED TO HOST A WONDERFUL
CONVERSATION, THE NEW BOOK
"GOING TO THE MOUNTAIN" WAS JUST
RELEASED YESTERDAY.
AND WE'RE HONORED TO WELCOME THE
AUTHOR, THE GRANDSON OF GLOBAL
HUMANITARIAN AND FORMER
PRESIDENT OF
SOUTH AFRICA, MANDELA AND HIS
GRANDSON, NDABA MANDELA. FIRST,
I WANT TO THANK MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS AND STAFF AND LIBRARY
STAFF WHO ARE HERE THIS
AFTERNOON.
ALSO THANK YOU TO OUR PARTNERS
WITH THE SOUTH AFRICA EMBASSY TO
HELP TO SPREAD THE WORD OF
TODAY'S DISCUSSION.
I WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO VISIT
THE DISPLAY AT THE FOYER ON THE
WAY OUT. YOU SAW IT ON THE WAY
IN.
ON THE DISPLAY ARE LIBRARY OF
MANDELA COLLECTIONS, INCLUDING
HIS BOOKS, WORKS, CHILDREN'S
BOOKS, AND A LOT OF OTHER STUFF.
TODAY WE'RE KICKING OFF A LOT OF
FUN ACTIVITIES THAT WILL BE
KICKING OFF AT THE LIBRARY THIS
SUMMER.
THIS MORNING, WE DID MEDIA
PREVIEW OF OUR BASEBALL
AMERICANA. THAT EXHIBIT OPENS
THIS FRIDAY.
HAPPENING THIS SUMMER AND IN A
COUPLE OF
WEEKS, WE'LL BE STARTING THE
SUMMER FILM SENTENCE
COINCIDENTALLY, NOT
COINCIDENTALLY, ACTUALLY. WE'LL
BE SCREENING FIELD OF DREAMS
OUTSIDE AND WE'LL START THE
SUMMER CONCERTS ON THE LAWN.
IT'S A BUSY SUMMER HERE AT THE
LIBRARY. WE HOPE YOU'LL COME
BACK. NOW TO TODAY'S EVENT,
FOLLOWING THE CONVERSATION,
THERE WILL BE A BOOK
SIGNING IN THE WOOD ITALL
PAVILION NEXT DOOR AND BOOKS
WILL BE ON SALE FOR YOU TO
PURCHASE. WE ASK YOU TO SILENCE
YOUR CELL PHONES OR TURN THEM
OFF. THE SPECIAL GUEST IS THE
AUTHOR OF
"GOING TO THE MOUNTAIN -- LIFE
LESSONS FROM MY GRAND PHAT,"
NELSON MANDELA.
THE STORY OF NELSON MANDELA IS
HIS STORY AND HOPING IT WILL BE
YOUR STORY.
HE'S CONTINUING HIS
GRANDFATHER'S
LEGACY AS CO-CHAIRMAN OF A
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO CREATE
A POSITIVE IMAGE FOR
AFRICA AROUND THE GLOBE AND
INCREASE GROWTH IN EDUCATIONAL,
EMPLOYMENT, AND INTERNATIONAL
ALLIANCES.
WELCOME TO THE LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS,
NDABA MANDELA AND THE 14th
DIRECTOR OF THE LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS, DR. CARLA HAYDEN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU.
OH, WOW. THIS IS SUCH A TREAT.
AND IT'S EVEN MORE OF A TREAT
BECAUSE YOUR BOOK JUST CAME OUT
YESTERDAY.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> AND I GOT A CHANCE TO READ IT
LAST NIGHT.
SO, WE'RE GOING TO DO -- BE ABLE
TO TALK ABOUT THE BOOK AND SOME
OF THE THINGS IN THERE. SO WE
JUST THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
>> MANDELA: AN ABSOLUTE PLEASURE
TO BE HERE.
>> HAYDEN: HAVE YOU BEEN TO
WASHINGTON, D.C. BEFORE?
>> MANDELA: I HAVE, I ATTENDED
THE BLACK CAUCUS TWICE.
>> HAYDEN: YOU CAN CLAP.
SO, WELL, IN THE BOOK, LET'S
JUST GET
TO IT -- HAVING THE LAST NAME
MANDELA AND WHAT IT MEANS TO
YOU, IS THERE A LOT OF PRESSURE
OR RESPONSIBILITY?
>> MANDELA: OF COURSE, OF
COURSE. I THINK PEOPLE HAVE A
LOT OF EXPECTATIONS, YOU KNOW,
OF BEING A MANDELA.  OF COURSE,
YOU KNOW, THEY CONSTANTLY WANT
TO PUT YOU IN THE FOOTSTEPS OF
NELSON MANDELA. AND WANT TO KNOW
WHAT ARE YOU DOING FOR YOUR
COMMUNITY, YOU KNOW?
LUCKILY, I AM DOING SOMETHING
FOR MY
COMMUNITY, THROUGH MY FOUNDATION
WHERE
ALL OF OUR EDUCATION AND
TECHNOLOGY AND
TECHNOLOGY AND CELEBRATING
AFRICAN CULTURE.
AND DEVELOPED ENTREPRENEURS IN
THE VILLAGES. YEAH.
>> HAYDEN: YOU MENTIONED
TECHNOLOGY. HOW DO YOU BRING
THAT IN?
>> MANDELA: SO BASICALLY WE'RE
RUNNING A THREE-MONTH COMPUTER
CODING PROGRAM.
WE HAVE -- WE'RE TRAINING 50
YOUTH, 40 IN HIGH SCHOOL AND THE
OTHER 20 UNEMPLOYUNEMPLOYED
YOUTH. ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES THAT WE
FACE IN AFRICA IS WE HAVE 60% TO
70% OF OUR YOUTH UNEMPLOYED.
AND UP TO MORE THAN 60% OF THEM
ARE UNEMPLOYABLE. THEY DON'T
HAVE THE SKILLS TO ACTUALLY BE
EMPLOYED. SO WE ARE TRYING TO DO
THAT THROUGH TEACHING THEM HOW
TO DO CODING.
AND THEY WRITE AN EXAM WITH
ORACLE AFTER THREE MONTHS.
THEY THEN QUALIFY FOR THE
QUALIICATION AND THEN WE FIND
THEM JOBS.
>> HAYDEN: AFTER THREE MONTHS.
>> MANDELA: YES. VERY BASIC.
>> HAYDEN: WOW, THAT'S QUITE
SOMETHING.
>> MANDELA: THEY HAVE A SKILL,
THEY HAVE
A CERTIFICATE THAT PROVES
THEY'RE PROFICIENT IN THAT
PARTICULAR MODEL, ENTRY LEVEL.
>> HAYDEN: NOW, SPEAKING OF
JUMPING RIGHT INTO THE BOOK, AS
A YOUNG MAN, AND
I CAN SEE WHERE TECHNOLOGY HAS
BEEN A THREAD, YOU WERE VERY
MUCH INTO CERTAIN VIDEO GAMES?
YOU MAY SAY WHICH ONES?
>> MANDELA: NORMAL ONES.
>> HAYDEN: REALLY.
>> MANDELA: SPORTS, MUSIC.
>> HAYDEN: MUSIC.
IT WAS INTERESTING TO HEAR YOU
DESCRIBE HIP-HOP AND ALL OF THE
THINGS LIKE THAT.
>> MANDELA: I WAS VERY LUCKY.
MY OLDER BROTHER, HE GREW UP IN
LONDON.
SO WHEN I WAS 17, HE WAS PLAYING
PUBLIC ENEMY.
THE FAT BOYS.
>> HAYDEN: THE FAT BOYS?
>> MANDELA: YES? AND, OF COURSE,
COOL J RAP. AND SO, YOU KNOW,
HE'S AN OLDER BROTHER AND I
REALLY LOOKED UP TO HIM, I
REALLY FOLLOWED HIM AND THE TEAM
HE SUPPORTED, THE LOCAL TEAM.
AND IN TERMS OF THE MUSIC IN
THIS INSTANCE. THE LABEL THAT HE
LIKED, HE WAS REALLY
A GREAT INFLUENCE FOR ME AT
THOSE FORMATIVE YEARS, TO BE
HONEST.
AND, I OF COURSE IDENTIFIED FROM
HIP-HOP BECAUSE WE COME FROM A
HISTORY OF FIGHTING THE POWERS
THAT BE, FIGHTING AGAINST THE
SYSTEM, FIGHTING AGAINST
APARTHEID. SO ENWHICH YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT BEING A REBEL,
IT'S SOMETHING THAT IN MY BLOOD
IT COMES FROM THE GENERATIONS.
HE HIMSELF WAS A REBEL AND HIS
FATHER HIMSELF WAS A REBEL.
BASICALLY MY GRANDFATHER WAS
BORN IN A RURAL VILLAGE. AND
THEN HIS FATHER GOT IN DISPUTE
WITH
ONE OF THE -- GOT IN TO A
DISPUTE.
AND BASICALLY PUNISHED THE
GENTLEMEN AND TOOK IT. AND HE
WENT TO THE WHITE MAGISTRATE TO
REPORT THIS MATTER.
AND SO THEY -- THEY BASICALLY
DENOUNCED
OR REMOVED THEM FROM OUR GREAT
GRANDFATHER. SO HE LEFT AND
MOVED BECAUSE HE WOULDN'T GIVE
BACK THE CAPITAL, BECAUSE HE
SAID, YOU HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH THIS. YOU DO NOT KNOW HOW I
RULE MY AREA. YOU HAVE NO RIGHT
TO COME AND TELL ME HOW I SHOULD
GOVERN MY AREA. SO PLEASE GET
AWAY. HE TOLD HIM TO -- TO LEAVE
HIM ALONE, BASICALLY. SO THEY
BASICALLY CAME WITH POLICE, ETC.
, ETC.
, AND THEY REMOVED HIM FORCIBLY.
SO HE SETTLED IN KUNU.
AND MY GRANDFATHER GREW UP, YOU
KNOW, SEEING HIM. BUT ANOTHER
THING HE WAS I GUESS
ATTRIBUTED TO IS WE COME FROM
THE RURAL KINGDOM AND WE COME
FROM THE FOUR PARTS. SO WE ARE A
POLYGAMIST NATION.
SO THE FIRST WIFE IS THE GREAT
HOUSE, THE SECOND WIFE IS THE
RIGHT-HAND HOUSE. THE THIRD WIFE
IS THE LEFT-HAND HOUSE, AND WE
COME FROM THE FOURTH HOUSE,
WHICH IS A JUNIOR HOUSE.
AND EVERY WIFE AFTER THAT COMES
FROM A JUNIOR HOUSE.
>> AND IN THE FOURTH HOUSE
SEEMED TO BE THE HOUSE THAT
MEDIATED BETWEEN THE OTHER
HOUSES?
>> THAT IS CORRECT.
SO OUR JOB FROM THE FOURTH HOUSE
WAS TO BE MEDIATORS AMONGST ALL
OF THE
HOUSES, ESPECIALLY AMONGST THE
FIRST TWO HOUSES BECAUSE THEY'RE
ALWAYS FIGHTING OVER THE CROWN.
AND THEN TO BE COUNSELOR TO THE
KING.
SO, YOU SEE, NELSON MANDELA DID
NOT FALL FROM THE HEAVENS AND
BECOME A GREAT PEACEMAKER, IT IS
IN HIS BLOOD, YOU UNDERSTAND.
THAT IS WHAT HE WAS ESSENTIALLY
RAISED TO DO, TO BECOME.
>> HAYDEN: THAT'S AN INTERESTING
IDEA OF HOW YOUR GRANDFATHER
DEVELOPED AND WHAT HE BROUGHT
WITH HIM.
YOU MENTIONED, AND THE NAME OF
THE BOOK REFERS TO SOMETHING.
>> MANDELA: YES.
>> HAYDEN: GOING TO THE
MOUNTAIN.
>> MANDELA "GOING TO THE
MOUNTAIN" REFERS TO TWO THINGS.
FIRSTLY, IN OUR CULTURE, WE HAVE
A RIGHT OF PASSAGE WHERE YOU
MOVE FROM BEING A
BOY TO BEING A MAN AND THAT IS
CIRCUMCISION.
WE ARE CIRCUMCISED BETWEEN THE
AGES OF 18 AND 21. BECAUSE WE
DON'T BELIEVE YOU CAN BE A MAN
AT THE AGE WHEN YOU'RE BORN. YOU
KNOW, USUALLY HERE IN THE WORLD,
YOU GET CIRCUMCISED WHEN YOU'RE
BORN.
>> HAYDEN: SPOILER ALERT,
THERE'S AN ENTIRE CHAPTER ON
YOUR EXPERIENCE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> MANDELA: FOR US, IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND FIRSTLY
HOW TO BECOME A MAN, YOU HAVE TO
EARN THE RIGHTS TO BECOME A MAN.
YOU DON'T JUST BECOME -- TURN 21
AND NOW YOU'RE REGARDED AS AN
ADULT, NO, YOU HAVE TO EARN THIS
RIGHT. YOU UNDERSTAND?
AND THAT'S THE FIRST THING THAT
HAPPENS IS THE CHOP --
>> HAYDEN: LET'S JUST SAY, THAT
WAS THE -- AT NIGHT, YOU'RE
READING THIS AND GOING OKAY.
I COULDN'T STOP READING.
>> MANDELA: THAT'S THE FIRST --
(LAUGHTER)
>> MANDELA: THAT'S REFERS TO THE
CIRCUMCISION PROCESS WE GO
THROUGH. IT'S RICH. BECAUSE YOU
GET TO UNDERSTAND WHO YOU
ARE, YOUR HISTORY, YOUR
HERITAGE, YOUR SPIRITUAL BEING
IN TERMS OF HOW YOU
RELATE TO OTHER TRIBES AND OTHER
CLANS.
AND SECOND, THE CHALLENGES, THE
JOURNEY
THAT ALL YOUNG BLACK PEOPLE IN
THIS WORLD, PEOPLE OF MINORITY.
WE FACE AN ENORMOUS TASK. YOU
HAVE TO GO AND APPLY TO COLLEGE.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE YOU GET
ENOUGH GOOD GRADES TO APPLY TO
COLLEGE.
AND THEN WHEN YOU'RE GET -- WHEN
YOU GET INTO COLLEGE, HOW ARE
YOU GOING TO PAY FOR THE TUITION
FEES? AND WHEN YOU FINISH
COLLEGE, HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
PAY BACK THOSE TUITION FEES? AND
NOW YOU MUST BEGIN YOUR CAREER.
SO THESE ARE ALL LITERAL
MOUNTAINS THAT WE'RE FACING AS
YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE
WORLD BECAUSE OUR JOB IS MUCH
HARDER THAN THE AVERAGE WHITE
WESTERNER WHO HAS GROWN UP IN
THIS PRIVILEGED WORLD, YOU SEE.
SO THIS IS WHAT GOING TO THE
MOUNTAIN MEANS.
AND AS NELSON MANDELA SAID,
AFTER CLIMBING A GREAT HILL, AND
YOU REACH THE TOP OF THAT HILL,
YOU REALIZE THERE ARE SO MANY
MORE MOUNTAINS TO CLIMB.
>> HAYDEN: AND YOU HAVE THE
PERSON THAT
WE ALL REVERE AND WE KNOW HIS
PUBLIC PERSONA. WHEN YOU WERE
11, YOU WENT TO LIVE WITH HIM.
>> MANDELA: YES.
>> HAYDEN: WHAT WAS -- JUST TELL
US ABOUT THAT.
>> MANDELA: YES, I WAS LIVING IN
A GHETTO IN JOHANNESBURG.
AND SO ONE DAY, THIS GENTLEMAN
CAME, MY GRANDFATHER'S DRIVER,
AND HE SAID, I'VE BEEN SENT BY
GRANDFATHER TO COME AND FETCH
YOU. COME, LET'S GO. THAT WAS --
I HAD ONLY MET MY GRANDFATHER
ONCE BEFORE IN 1990. THIS IS
THREE YEARS LATER.
>> HAYDEN: WAS HE IN PRISON
THEN? RIGHT?
>> MANDELA: WE MET HIM JUST
BEFORE HE CAME OUT OF PRISON.
AND THIS IS THREE YEARS LATER,
NEVER SAW HIM, NEVER HEARD FROM
HIM.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, A DRIVER TOOK
HIM AND WAS SENT BY HIM.
I'M HOME ALONE BECAUSE I'M AT
HOME AT 3:00 P.M.
MY PARENTS GET HOME AT 7:00 P.M.
FROM WORK.
SO I'M NOT GOING TO GO WITHOUT
THE APPROVAL OF MY PARENTS. NO
CELL PHONES IN THOSE DAYS. DO
YOU KNOW WHO YOUR GRANDFATHER
IS? ARE YOU CRAZY?
DO I NEED TO LOSE MY JOB?
PLEASE, LET'S GO!
I SAID, NO, SIR, I CANNOT.E GAVE
UP.
MY PARENTS CAME HOME THAT
EVENING AND I TOLD MY FATHER
WHAT HAD TRANSPIRED AND HE SAID,
YOU KNOW, IF THAT MAN COMES
AGAIN, YOU SHOULD GO WITH HIM.
LO AND BEHOLD, THAT MAN CAME
BACK THE VERY SAME WEEK.
AND I WENT TO THEM AND HE TOOK
ME TO MY GRANDFATHER'S HOUSE,
WHICH WAS THIS BIG
HOUSE, A MANSION IN A WHITE
SUBURB IN
THE NORTHERN SUBURBS OF
JOHANNESBURG, AND, YOU KNOW,
BASICALLY MY GRANDFATHER
TOLD ME THAT HE WOULD BE SENDING
MY PARENTS TO COLLEGE AND WHILE
THEY WERE AT COLLEGE, THEY
NEEDED TO FOCUS ON SCHOOL AND HE
WAS GOING TO LOOK AFTER ME
DURING THAT TIME.
I SLEPT OVER THAT DAY. MY FATHER
CAME THE NEXT DAY AND HE SAID,
YEAH, WELL, THIS IS WHAT MY
FATHER HAS DECIDED -- YOUR
GRANDFATHER -- AND THIS IS
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN. AS A
YOUNG PERSON IN ANY AFRICAN
FAMILY, YOU DON'T HAVE MUCH
CHOICE. YOU DO AS YOU'RE TOLD.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS.
AND NOW FROM A GHETTO, FROM
SLEEPING, EATING RICE AND TOMATO
SAUCE, THAT WAS MY STAPLE DIET,
BECAUSE WE GREW UP IN A
POOR HOME, TO MOVING INTO THIS
MANSION WHERE THERE ARE CHEFS,
DRIVERS, SECURITY, GARDINERS,
STAFF, STAFF, STAFF, STAFF,
STAFF.
>> HAYDEN: YOU MENTIONED YOU
FELT LIKE "THE FRESH PRINCE OF
BELL AIR."
>> MANDELA: KIND OF WAS LIKE
THAT, YOU KNOW? TO BE HONEST?
YOU WENT AND THERE YOU WERE. AND
THERE HE WAS.
BUT A PRIVATE PERSON THAT MOST
OF US COULD NEVER IMAGINE. WHAT
WAS THAT LIKE?
>> HE WAS ACTUALLY -- THE FIRST
CUP ALL
OF YEARS, THERE WASN'T MUCH
CONVERSATION HAPPENING.
HE WAS A DISCIPLINARIAN. HE TOLD
ME EVERY TIME MY ROOM WAS IN A
MESS.
THINGS THAT REVOLVED AROUND
SCHOOL, WHAT I NEEDED FOR
SCHOOL, BOOKS, UNIFORMS, SPORTS,
ALL ABOUT HOW THE REPORT CARD
WAS LOOKING. NOT MUCH OUTSIDE OF
SCHOOL STUFF, BASICALLY. AND I
REMEMBER ONCE, I LOST MY JERSEY
-- MY SCHOOL JERSEY FOR THE
SECOND TIME.
AND, OF COURSE, I HAD TO TELL
HIM, I NEEDED A NEW ONE. I WENT
AND I TOLD HIM AND I WAS VERY
NERVOUS.
HE CHANGED HIS FACE ALL OF A
SUDDEN. TONIGHT YOU'RE GOING TO
SLEEP OUTSIDE!
OH, OKAY. OUT I WENT, OUTSIDE. I
WAS PLAYING SOCCER IN THE
GARAGE.
IRS AT FIRST, IT WAS KIND OF
OKAY. STARTED TO GET COLD, DARK.
I SAW THE COOK BRING ME
BLANKETS.
SHE GAVE ME THE BLANKET AND I
THOUGHT, OH, MY GOD, I'M REALLY
GOING TO SLEEP OUTSIDE.
MAYBE 20 MINUTES, I MAKE MY
LITTLE BED ON THE GRASS.
AND THEN 20 MINUTES LATER I CAME
UP AND HE CALLED ME AND HE SAID
IF YOU EVER LOSE ANOTHER JERSEY,
YOU WILL DEFINITELY SLEEP
OUTSIDE, NOW GO INSIDE, HAVE
YOUR DINNER AND GO STRAIGHT TO
BED.
IT WAS KIND OF HARSH BUT IT
WORKED. I NEVER LOST ANOTHER
JERSEY.
>> YOU HAVE THAT RELATIONSHIP
WHERE HE MENTIONED HE WAS THE
DISCIPLINARIAN.
IN HINDSIGHT, DO YOU THINK THAT
YOU NEEDED IT?
>> OF COURSE, OF COURSE. I WAS A
LITTLE KNUCKLE HEAD BACK THEN.
I JUST WANTED TO HAVE FUN AND
FUN AND MORE FUN. WHETHER IT WAS
-- WASN'T PLAY STATION BACK
THEN, IT WAS SAGA.  YOU KNOW? OR
SOCCER. YOU KNOW? THAT WAS -- OR
WATCHING A MOVIE.
I'D GO TO HIM ON FRIDAY,
SATURDAY, HEY, CAN I HAVE 50
RAND TO GO WATCH A MOVIE WITH MY
FRIENDS. AND HE WOULD ALWAYS
GIVE ME. NOT ONE TIME HE SAID
NO.
>> HAYDEN: SO THERE WAS A
SOFTNESS UNDER THERE.
>> MANDELA: YES.
>> HAYDEN: I WROTE THIS DOWN, TO
BE THE FATHER OF A NATION WAS A
GREAT HONOR BUT TO BE FATHER OF
A FAMILY WAS A GREAT JOY, A JOY
I HAD FAR TOO LITTLE OF. AND IN
THE YEARS OF IMPRISONMENT, HE
MISSED THAT. SO WITH YOU HE HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO IT.
>> I GUESS SO. I GUESS SO.
I MEAN, I ALSO STAYED WITH MY
GRANDMOTHER A LITTLE BIT,
GRANDMA WINNIE. HE COULD HAVE
SENT ME TO GO STAY WITH HER.
OR MY REAL GRANDMOTHER FROM THE
FIRST MARRIAGE, HIS FIRST WIFE
WAS STILL ALIVE. MY AUNT WAS
STILL AROUND.
BUT HE DECIDED TO TAKE ME IN AND
STAY WITH HIM. HE HAD OPTIONINGS
BUT HE DECIDED I'M GOING TO
DISCIPLINE THIS YOUNG MAN, I'M
GOING TO SHOW HIM THE WAY OF
LIFE. SO PERHAPS THAT WAS HIS
WAY OF MAKING
SOME SORT OF, YOU KNOW,
COMPENSATION OR RESTITUTION OR
WHAT -- BE THE FATHER FIGURE
THAT HE NEVER HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT BECAUSE
HE HAD TO MAKE THE ULTIMATE
SACRIFICE.
UNFORTUNATELY.
INSTEAD OF TAKING HIS KID TO GO
RIDE
BIKES, HE HAD TO GO ORGANIZE
PEACEFUL PROTESTS AND MARCHES
AND STRATEGIZE HOW TO KEEP THE
ANC ALIVE WHILE IT WAS BAD. HE
HAD SO MANY THINGS TO DO TO
FOCUS ON TB COUNTRY. SO HE HAD
TO MAKE A VERY HARD DECISION.
SATISFY HIS FAMILY OR FIVE
PEOPLE OR THE GREATER GOOD OR 4
MILLION OR 5 MILLION.
>> AND YOU MENTIONED THAT IN
PRIVATE HE WAS SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE COULD SEE --
HUMBLE AND FORGIVING.
AND HE HAD A SENSE OF HUMOR,
THOUGH.
>> MANDELA: GREAT SENSE OF
HUMOR. HE WAS MISCHIEVOUS WITH
HIS HUMOR, TO BE HONEST WITH
YOU.
ONE TIME I HAD ASKED A FEMALE
FRIEND TO COME OVER FOR LUNCH.
AND SO HE SAYS, OH, NICE TO MEET
YOU.  SO DID YOU PROPOSE TO MY
GRANDSON?
>> HAYDEN: OKAY.
>> MANDELA: YOU CAN IMAGINE THE
YOUNG LADY BLUSHING.
>> HAYDEN: SHE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT.
>> MANDELA: HE WAS ALWAYS TRYING
TO THROW ME -- LIKE, HEY, HAVE
YOU SEEN MINUTE GRANDSON. I WAS
A BIT TOO YOUNG.
BECAUSE YOU USED TO HAVE -- MISS
SOUTH AFRICA WOULD COME OVER,
MISS UNIVERSE
WOULD COME OVER, MISS WORLD
WOULD COME OVER. I WAS IN AWE
BUT I WAS WAY TOO I DON'T THINK.
I COULDN'T REALLY HANG.
HE DIDN'T CARE. HE WOULD BE JUST
LIKE, HEY, DID YOU SEE MY
GRANDSON?
THAT WAS PRETTY NICE.
>> HAYDEN: SO DURING THIS TIME,
HE BECAME PRESIDENT OF THE
NATION. WERE YOU AWARE OF THOSE
-- HE WAS WORKING WITH YOU AND
BEING PART OF YOUR LIFE, BUT HE
WAS HELPING TO BUILD THE NATION
AGAIN?
>> MANDELA: YES, HE WAS VERY
BUSY. HE TRAVELLED A LOT, OF
COURSE.
THERE WERE MANY WEEKS I DIDN'T
SEE HIM.
IT WAS FUN, I COULD GET AWAY
WITH MURDER.
I COULD PLAY GAMES UNTIL 2:00 IN
THE MORNING. AND NO ONE WOULD
SAY ANYTHING. BUT WHEN HE WAS
HOME, HEY, THE CHIEF IS HOME.
YOU HAD TO KEEP EVERYTHING IN
LINE. BUT THE ONE THING I
REALIZED ABOUT HIM
IS THAT THAT'S A MAN WITH SO
MUCH COMPASSION FOR PEOPLE, FOR
ORDINARY PEOPLE.
YOU CAN IMAGINE -- MICHAEL
JACKSON HAD BEEN TO OUR HOME
TWICE.
EVEN FORMER PRESIDENT BUSH,
EVANDER HOLYFIELD, MIKE TYSON,
YOU NAME IT.
AND ALL THESE PEOPLE THAT
VISITED US HE TREATED THE SAME
WAY AS
MAMA KOLI WHO COOKED FOR US,
ALSO AS THE GARDENER AND THE
DRIVER.
ONE THING NELSON MANDELA
UNDERSTOOD SIMILAR TO MARTIN
LUTHER KING, YOU DON'T JUDGE
PEOPLE BY THEIR SKIN COLOR,
THEIR AGE, RACE, SEXUALITY.
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT EACH PERSON
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO ACHIEVE
GREATNESS AND WE SHOULD ALLOW
THAT PERSON TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ACHIEVE THE
GREATNESS THEY WANT TO ACHIEVE
FOR THEMSELVES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> HAYDEN: YOU MENTIONED HE
TREATED EVERYONE THE SAME. I WAS
REALLY TAKEN WITH HIS PHONE CALL
WITH QUEEN ELIZABETH. WE THINK
OF HER
>> MANDELA: I KNOW, I KNOW.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT SHE WAS ALSO
VERY MISCHIEVOUS WITH
GRANDFATHER. I REMEMBER ONE
AFTERNOON -- NOT SURE I SHOULD
TELL THIS STORY.
>> HAYDEN: OH, DO.
>> MANDELA: IT'S A BIT LATE NOW.
A BIT LATE  GRAND DAD, PLEASE
FORGIVE ME FOR THIS ONE.
WE WERE HAVING LUNCH, ME, MY
GRANDFATHER
AND AUNTIE -- MAMA KOLI COMES
AND THE PHONE NUMBER COMES IN.
WE USED TO CALL HIM FATHER --
TATA -- IT'S QUEEN ELIZABETH ON
THE LINE.
PUT HER THROUGH, PUT HER
THROUGH. AND THEN THE PHONE
COMES. HE PICKS IT UP. HELLO,
ELIZABETH, HOW ARE YOU?
(LAUGHTER)  AND THEY HAVE A
CONVERSATION.
THEY TALK, THEY TALK.
YOU KNOW, EVENTUALLY, BYE, BYE.
AND HOW CAN YOU CALL THE QUEEN
BY HER NAME, YOU HAVE TO SAY
YOUR IMAGESTY!
AND HE TURNED TO HER AND SAY,
WHY, SHE CALLS ME NELSON?
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> HAYDEN: WOW.
>> MANDELA: WE ALWAYS CALL EACH
OTHER BY OUR FIRST NAME. DO YOU
FORGET I'M A PRINCE. DO YOU
FORGET I'M A PRINCE, DARLING?
HMM? WHERE IS THE LOYALTY HERE.
>> HAYDEN: WOW.
SO YOU HAVE THE PRIVATE SIDE AND
YOU KNOW ABOUT HIS LEGACY.
THAT'S WHY SO MANY PEOPLE ARE
HERE AND WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU
ABOUT HOW SOME OF THE LESSONS
THAT YOU THINK CAN BE APPLIED
TODAY.
THERE WAS A LOT ABOUT
RECONCILIATION,
AND BEING ABLE TO LET GO OF,
NOW, NEVER TO FORGET THE HATE,
BUT TO LET THINGS GO.  TO
RECONCILE.
>> MANDELA: YES, YOU KNOW, I
THINK NELSON MANDELA OBVIOUSLY
HE TRIED THE PEACEFUL WAY.
RIGHT?  A PEACEFUL MARCH.
BUT HE SAYS IN AN INTERVIEW THAT
ALL THE PEACEFUL MARCHES,
IMPORTANT AS
THEY WERE, THEY WERE ONLY MET
WITH
VIOLENCE AND SAVAGE ATTACKS BY
THE GOVERNMENT. SO THEY DECIDED
TO NOW TAKE UP MILITARY ACTION
AGAINST THE GOVERNMENT.
AND SO HE BECAME THE FIRST
COMMANDER IN CHIEF OF THE
MILITARY ARM OF THE ANC.
HE TRAINED IN ALGERIA FOR SIX
MONTHS. AND SIX MONTHS WITH AN
EMPEROR.
AND HE CAME BACK AND STARTED
OBVIOUSLY HITTING BACK AT THE
ENEMY. BUT THEY DIDN'T OBVIOUSLY
ATTACK PEOPLE.
THEY ATTACKED THE INFRASTRUCTURE
OF THEIR GOVERNMENTS.
SO THEY ATTACKED THE POWER
LINES, THE POWER STATIONS, THEY
ATTACKED THE TELEPHONE
INFRASTRUCTURE, BASICALLY. BUT,
OF COURSE, THERE WERE CASUALTIES
AS IS IN ANY WAR.
CAPTURED AND SPENT TIME IN
PRISON.
HE GOT TO SEE THE INDEPENDENCE
THAT WAS
HAPPENING ACROSS AFRICA, FROM
1960 GHANA
TO 1980 IN ZIMBABWE AND MOST OF
THE COUNTRIES WERE GAINING
INDEPENDENCE IN AFRICA WERE
GOING THROUGH CIVIL WAR.
AND I THINK HE REALLY WANTED TO
STOP THE CYCLE OF VIOLENCE THAT
WAS REALLY
EATING AWAY AT OUR
COUNTRY, OUR SOCIETY.
AND AS HE CAME OUT, HE DECIDED
TO OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW, FORGIVE
HIS CAPTORS. FORGIVE THOSE
PEOPLE WHO TRESPASS AGAINST HIM,
YOU KNOW?
AND THE ONE THING THAT I HAVE TO
ASK MYSELF IS, FIRST OF ALL,
THAT IS ONE SUPER UNNATURAL
THING TO DO, BECAUSE IF I WAS
THERE FOR FIVE YEARS, EVEN, LET
ALONE 27 YEARS, FIVE YEARS, I
WOULD COME
OUT WITH THE VENGEANCE AND THE
ANGER OF -- OF A GORILLA, RIGHT?
AND I WOULD WANT TO BLAST ALL OF
MY ENEMIES.
BUT HE DIDN'T. WHICH IS
SOMETHING VERY UNNATURAL.
SECONDLY, A LOT OF COUNTRIES --
LEADERS WHO WERE CAUGHT WERE
KILLED IN INCARCERATION. THEY
DIDN'T LAST LONG. SO HOW COME
NELSON MANDELA WAS NOT KILLED?
WHY WAS NELSON MANDELA SPARED?
AND THE ONLY ANSWER THAT I CAN
COME TO IS THAT GOD SAVED HIM.
THAT GOD WAS THE ONE WHO WAS ON
THE SIDE AND KEPT HIM ALIVE FOR
A SPECIFIC
PURPOSE THAT HE HAD TO PLAY
AFTER HE CAME OUT OF PRISON.
AND SO HE UNDERSTOOD THAT THEY
NEEDED
TO CURE THIS  VICIOUS CYCLE OF
VIOLENCE THAT WAS TAKING OUR
COUNTRY.
AND HE AND BISHOP TUTU CAME UP
WITH
THE TRUTH AND
RECONCILIATION TALKS THAT CAME
OUT OF
THE 90s, THOSE WHO HAD LOST
LOVED ONES, TORTURED, WRONGFULLY
INCARS RATED FOR MANY YEARS --
INCARCERATED FOR MANY YEARS TO
SIT WITH
THEIR VICTIMS AND HAVE SOME SORT
OF RESTORITIVE JUSTICE AND FOR
THE PERPETRATORS BE ABLE TO
DEVOLVE EVERY BIT OF INFORMATION
IN RETURN FOR AMNESTY. A LOT OF
PEOPLE FEEL THAT IT WASN'T
REALLY SUCCESSFUL.
BUT I THINK IT REALLY LAY THE
FOUNDATION TO TRY AND GET THE
BALL ROLLING FOR A NEW DISPEN
SAYINGS, FOR A NEW COUNTRY, CALL
IT THE RAINBOW NATION.
THAT WOULD BE -- AND THEN PEOPLE
UNDERSTOOD THE VALUE OF PEACE
AND HARMONY OVER THE CONTINUED
VIOLENCE THAT THEY'D BEEN
EXPERIENCING FOR SO MANY
DECADES.
AND I THINK IT WAS JUST HIS WAY
OF
TRYING TO -- TO AMEND AND TO --
AND TO ELIMINATE HIS ENEMIES.
YOU KNOW? BECAUSE ONE OF THE
THINGS YOU SAID WAS THAT IN
ORDER TO DEFEAT YOUR ENEMY, YOU
MUST WORK WITH YOUR UH ENEMY,
BECAUSE THEN HE BECOMES YOUR
PARTNER.
>> HAYDEN:
AND HE HAD YOU LEARN AFTERRY KAN
-- AFRIKKAN.
>> MANDELA: I DIDN'T LEARN IT.
I DID LEARN A LITTLE BIT PCHLT
THERE ARE
MANY AFRIKKAN SPEAKING PEOPLE
HERE? NO. I WAKE UP IN THE
MORNING, HE WOULD BE IN THE
LOUNGE, HE WOULD READ THE
NEWSPAPERS BACK-TO-BACK.
HE WAS VERY FLUENT IN AFRIKKANS.
READING AND WRITING.
SO MUCH SO THAT EVEN IN JAIL,
THE WARDEN THAT WAS LOOKING
AFTER THE CELL HAD TO BE CHANGED
EVERY THREE MONTHS
BECAUSE WHAT THEY FOUND WAS THAT
NELSON
MANDELA WOULD BE ABLE TO REALLY
CONNECT WITH ANY HUMAN BEING,
INCLUDING THE GUARDS, RIGHT?
INCLUDING THE GUARDS.
SO HOW HE DID IT IS THAT THE
GUARDS
WOULD RECEIVE LETTERS FROM THE
LOVED
ONES, BUT THEY WERE NOT AS
EDUCATED AS HE WAS IN THEIR OWN
LANGUAGE.
SO HE WOULD TRANSLATE THE
LETTERS FOR THE WARDEN THAT WERE
LOOKING AFTER HIM.
AND THEN HE WAS VERY HAPPY HE
UNDERSTANDS AND NOW HE WOULD
CONVINCE THEM TO SMUGGLE HIM AN
EXTRA FEW SLICES OF BREAD, AN
EXTRA COUPLE OF ORANGES AND
FRUITS, AN EXTRA BLANKET, SOME
EXTRA JACKETS, YOU UNDERSTAND?
ONCE THE AUTHORITIES FOUND THIS
OUT, OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE
COMPLETELY, COMPLETELY, YOU
KNOW, ANGRY. SO THEY CHANGED THE
GUARD. AND EVEN THOUGH THEY'D
CHANGE THE GUARD, THE SAME THING
WOULD HAPPEN AGAIN.
SO EVEN IN PRISON, THERE WAS NO
ONE
GUARD THAT COULD LOOK AFTER
NELSON MANDELA WITHOUT HIM
ENDING UP BECOMING A FRIEND OF
NELSON MANDELA.
THAT IS THE SPIRIT AND THE POWER
OF MANDIBA.
I BELIEVE HE HAD A GIFT FROM GOD
THAT HE COULD CONNECT WITH HIS
COMPASSION TO ANYBODY, WHETHER
THAT PERSON SPOKE ENGLISH OR
NOT.
BUT HE WOULD BE ABLE TO CONNECT
WITH YOU.
>> HAYDEN: DO YOU THINK HE
REALIZED? HE KNEW HE HAD THIS
GIFT? OR HE HAD THIS
RESPONSIBILITY?
>> MANDELA: I THINK HE KNEW HE
HAD THIS RESPONSIBILITY. I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT THE GIFT.
BUT I THINK HE DEFINITELY KNEW
THAT HE HAD THIS RESPONSIBILITY.
AND I CAN SAY THAT BECAUSE HE
TAUGHT ME --
HE TOLD ME, DABA, YOU'RE A
MANDELA, THEREFORE PEOPLE WILL
LOOK AT YOU AS A LEADER.
AND AS A LEADER, YOU MUST GET
THE BEST MARKS IN CLASS. I WAS
LIKE, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
YOU KNOW? I WANTED TO BE A
NORMAL KID.
AND PLAY AND HAVE FUN AND DO A
NORMAL KID. I DON'T HAVE THE
PLEASURE OF HAVING TO STUDY ALL
-- EVERY DAY SO THAT I CAN HAVE
THE BEST MARKS IN CLASS SO I CAN
BE A LEADER? YOU KNOW? FOR ME, I
DON'T REALLY UNDERSTAND IT AT
THE TIME. ONLY MUCH LATER THAT I
COME TO GRIPS WITH IT.
>> HAYDEN: AND SO YOU'VE BEEN
ABLE TO, WITH YOUR FOUNDATION
AND TO REALLY SEE HOW YOU CAN
KEEP IT.
>> MANDELA: YES, YES.
OBVIOUSLY, INSPIRED ME
INDIRECTLY TO START THIS
FOUNDATION. BUT YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE MAIN REASONS I STARTED THIS
FOUNDATION IS I WAS LUCKY
TO BE ABLE TO TRAVEL, YOU KNOW,
WITH MY GRANDFATHER AND WITHOUT
HIM.
AND I REMEMBER MY FIRST TRIP
HERE IN -- IN AMERICA, WE WENT
TO DISNEY WORLD, OF COURSE.
I WAS 18 YEARS OLD WITH MY
YOUNGER AND OLDER BROTHERS AND
COUSINS.
AND WE WERE TRYING TO GET ON THE
ROLLER COASTER. YOU GET IN THE
LINE, YOU GET IN FRONT OF THE
QUEUE, EVENTUALLY. AND THE
GENTLEMAN HI, HOW ARE YOU? WHERE
ARE YOU FROM? I'M FROM SOUTH
AFRICA.
HE SAYS TO ME, WELL, HOW BIG DO
THE LIONS GET.
I LOOKED AT MY COUSIN AND SAID,
SORRY, SIR, I DON'T WORK AT THE
ZOO. I HAVE NO IDEA HOW BIG
LIONS GET.
THEN WE TRAVEL TO LONDON AND
SOMEBODY SAYS, HEY, WOW, YOU
KNOW, HI, HOW ARE YOU?
AFRICA, I HEARD IT'S DANGEROUS.
I NEED SECURITY TO COME TO SOUTH
AFRICA. IT'S QUITE SAFE. MY
GRANDFATHER WAS PRESIDENT, I
DON'T EVEN HAVE SECURITY. I
THINK YOU'LL BE JUST FINE.
YOU'LL BE JUST FINE. THEN WE
TRAVEL TO NEW YORK. AND ANOTHER
PERSON CAME IN THE SAME FASHION.
AND THEN I REALIZED, OH, MAN,
THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG HERE.
PEOPLE OUTSIDE OF OUR CONTINENT
HAVE A VERY SKEWED PERCEPTION OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON OUR
CONTINENT.
AND THIS IS MAINLY PERPETUATED
BY MAIN STREAM MEDIA THAT AFRICA
IS A PLACE OF WAR, POVERTY,
DISEASE, AND DICTATORS.
NOW, WE'RE NOT HERE TO DENY
THESE THINGS EXIST, HOWEVER,
THERE ARE A LOT OF QUALITY
THINGS THAT ARE GOOD IN AFRICA
THAN WHAT YOU SEE ON YOUR TV.
AND SO WE DECIDED TO START
SOMETHING. WE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
IT WAS.
WE DECIDED TO START SOMETHING.
SO WHEN I GOT BACK HOME, ME AND
MY COUSIN CALLED OUR COLLEAGUES,
RIGHT? AND I SAID, GUYS, THERE'S
SOMETHING WRONG WITH THE IMAGE
OF AFRICA.
WE NEED TO CHANGE IT. AND WHAT I
REALIZED THAT DAY IS I WAS NOT
SPECIAL BECAUSE MOST OF THE
PEOPLE I CALLED TO THE MEETING
FELT THE VERY SAME WAY.
SO IT WASN'T I AM IN THE HEART
OF AFRICAN YOUTH IN GENERAL,
THEY FEEL THE SAME WAY I DO.
THEY'VE SEEN IT AND EXPERIENCED
IT. SO THAT DAY WE DECIDED TO BE
A FOUNDATION, A NON-PROFITABLE
ORGANIZATION THAT FOCUSES ON
YOUTH EMPOWERMENT BECAUSE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE TASK AT HAND
IS NOT GOING TO BE ACHIEVED
OVERNIGHT. IT'S GOING TO TAKE
TWO OR THREE GENERATIONS FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE THE
BREAKING DOWN OF THE
MISCONCEPTION OF A AFRICA SO
THEY CAN SEE IT AS A PLACE WHERE
THEY CAN GO ON HOLIDAY, THEY CAN
SEE IT AS A PLACE WHERE THEY CAN
DO BUSINESS. THIS IS A PLACE --
YOU
LOOK AT THE TOP TEN GROWING
ECONOMIES IN THE WORLD RIGHT
NOW, SEVEN OF THOSE ARE COMING
FROM THE CONTINENT OF AFRICA.
RIGHT? MANY PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
THAT. YOU WANT REAL GROWTH AND
INVESTMENT AND RETURN ON YOUR
CAPITAL.  COME TO AFRICA.
YOU WANT TO HAVE FUN AND
EXPERIENCE THE MOST TROPICAL AND
AMAZING ISLANDS, COME TO AFRICA.
YOU WANT THE FRESHEST, CLEANEST
GARMENT DRAPING DOWN YOUR BODY,
COME TO AFRICA.
[ APPLAUSE ]
I MEAN, WHEN YOU LOOK AT ALL OF
THE FASHION HOUSES, WHETHER IT
BE LOUIS
VUITTON, HUGO BOSS, HI END, LOW
END, THEY'RE ALL SEEKING
INSPIRATION FROM AFRICA.
NOT GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE
MUSIC AND DANCING.
>> HAYDEN: I WAS GOING TO ASK.
AND ART.
>> MANDELA: SO WE BASICALLY
FOCUS ON YOUNG PEOPLE AT THE
HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL,
FOCUS ON EDUCATION, FOR
DEVELOPMENT, AND TECHNOLOGY.
SO WE ARE CURRENTLY RUNNING A
THREE-MONTH CODING PROGRAM FOR
40 KIDS
IN HIGH SCHOOL AND 20 UNEMPLOYED
YOUTH.
AND IN SOUTH AFRICA, ONE OF OUR
CHALLENGES IS WE HAVE 60% TO 70%
OF OUR YOUTH ARE UNEMPLOYED AND
OVER 60% OF THEM ARE
UNEMPLOYABLE BECAUSE THEY DO NOT
HAVE SKILLS.
TO ACTUALLY GET A JOB.
>> HAYDEN: WHAT ABOUT THE SCHOOL
SYSTEMS?
I KNOW THERE WAS --
THERE WERE DIVISIONS AND THINGS.
SO, NOW, HOW ARE YOUR EDUCATION
SYSTEMS?
>> MANDELA: YOU KNOW, THE STORY
OF SOUTH AFRICA IS THAT WE HAVE
THE PRIVATE AND THE PUBLIC. THE
PRIVATE SCHOOLS IN SOUTH AFRICA
ARE SOME OF THE BEST IN THE
WORLD, HAVE THE BEST FACILITIES
IN THE WORLD. AND CAN REALLY
COMPARE TO ANY IN THE WORLD.
BUT THE PUBLIC NOT AS GOOD -- WE
HAD A FEW GOOD PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
BUT THE MAJORITY OF THEM ARE
LACKING IN MANY WAYS.  YOU KNOW?
WHETHER IT'S THE ATTITUDE OF THE
TEACHERS, YOU KNOW? THE
FACILITIES.
BUT SHEER DOWN THE MANAGEMENT OF
RESOURCES OR LACK OF RESOURCES
WHEN IT COMES TO THE PUBLIC
SECTOR. I MEAN, I KNOW A SCHOOL
WHICH IS NOT
TOO FAR FROM OUR VILLAGE, THEY
ARE STUDYING IN A -- YOU KNOW,
THE SHIPMENT CONTAINERS, THAT IS
A SCHOOL.
THE SHIPMENT CONTAINER -- A
WHOLE SCHOOL.
LOOKING AFTER ABOUT 200
CHILDREN.
AND IT'S A RAGGEDY, RAGGEDY,
TERRIBLE SHAPE.
RECENTLY BEFORE I CAME HERE, THE
TEACHER
WHO TOLD ME THAT IT HAS HOLES ON
THE FLOOR AND THERE'S BEEN
INCIDENTS WHERE SNAKES CREEP UP
THROUGH -- I MEAN, CAN YOU
IMAGINE A 5-YEAR-OLD,
6-YEAR-OLD? THAT'S THE MOST
TRAUMATIC THING. THAT'S THE MOST
TRAUMATIC THING. SO HOW CAN YOU
-- THESE KIDS ARE NOT LOOKING
FORWARD TO GOING TO SCHOOL.  YOU
KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
THEY'RE NOT LOOKING FORWARD TO
GOING TO SCHOOL. THEY DON'T KNOW
THE FACT THAT THEY CAN'T EVEN
AFFORD FOOD, HOW CAN YOU LEARN
ON AN EMPTY STOMACH.
SO THE WEIRD THING IS THAT SOUTH
AFRICA, OUR COUNTRY IN
PARTICULAR, HAS
BOTH ASPECTS OF A DEVELOPING AND
A DEVELOPED COUNTRY, WE HAVE THE
BEST AND THE WORST IN OUR
COUNTRY.
THE BEST AND THE WORST.
YOU'LL SAY, OH, MY GOD, I'M BACK
IN THE STONE AGES. LOOKS LIKE
HELL. AND THEN THERE ARE PARTS
WHERE YOU SAY,
OH, MY GOD, LOOK AT THIS, I MUST
BE IN MONACO!
THIS IS AMAZING. THAT IS SOUTH
AFRICA TODAY.
SO IT'S A QUESTION OF HOW DO WE
CLOSE THE GAP, YOU KNOW? THAT IS
OUR BIGGEST CHALLENGE RIGHT NOW.
>> HAYDEN: THIS JULY, YOUR
GRANDFATHER WOULD HAVE TURNED
100 YEARS OLD.
AND ARE THERE PLANS FOR A
CENTENNIAL? BECAUSE I REALLY
WANTED TO -- BEFORE WE OPEN IT
UP FOR QUESTIONS, I WANTED TO --
>> MANDELA: AWESOME PLANS. THE
NELSON MANDELA FOUNDATION, THEY
HAVE THE ANNUAL LECTURE THAT'S
BEEN GIVEN BY BARACK OBAMA AND
MICHELLE OBAMA
OF THIS YEAR, THAT WILL BE THE
17th OF JULY.
UNFORTUNATELY, WE WERE GOING TO
HAVE A GALA DINNER.
IT HAD TO BE POSTPONED SO WE'VE
POSTPONED IT TO THE 1st OF
DECEMBER, IT'S WORLD AIDS DAY.
HIV-AIDS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
PLAYED A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN MY
LIFE.
I LOST BOTH OF MY PARENTS TO
HIV/AIDS.
AND SINCE THEN, HAVE BECOME ONE
OF THE
LONGEST SERVING AMBASSADORS OF
U.N.-AIDS.
HAVING TRAVELLED TO, YOU KNOW,
BRAZIL, GENEVA, SWITZERLAND,
TALKING ABOUT THIS EPIDEMIC.
RECENTLY, I WAS IN RUSSIA SPEAK
EGG AT THE EAST EUROPEAN AIDS
CONFERENCE.  SO, YEAH.
I MEAN, WE ARE
BY MANY WAYS THE AVERAGE
FAMILIES.
WE'RE AFFECTED BY SOMETHING THAT
AFFECTS ALL OF SOUTH AFRICANS,
WE HAVE MANDELA, THIS PATRIARCH,
OUR LEADER,
WE'RE VERY MUCH THE SAME AS
THOSE AVERAGE FAMILIES TODAY.
>> HAYDEN: YOUR GRANDFATHER LEFT
A LEGACY FELT GLOBALLY. I KNOW
YOU CARRIED ON. WHAT ARE SOME OF
THE LIFE LESSONS YOU THINK HE
TAUGHT YOU AND THAT WE CAN ALL
LOOK FORWARD TO?
>> MANDELA: THE ONE LESSON WE
TAUGHT ME
WAS, NDABA, YOU MUST ALWAYS BE
HUMBLE, HUMILITY IS VERY
IMPORTANT, ESPECIALLY FOR A
LEADER.
YOU HAVE TO BE -- YOU HAVE TO BE
ACCESSIBLE.
AND YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THE
PEOPLE THAT YOU'RE SERVING.
BECAUSE AS A LEADER, YOU ARE A
SERVANT.
YOU'RE NOT THERE TO BOAST, TO
SHOW HOW
MUCH, WHAT A GREAT CAR YOU HAVE
OR HOW MANY THINGS YOU HAVE.
THAT'S NOT A LEADER.
LEADERS ARE NOT THERE TO SHOW
I'M NUMBER ONE, LOOK AT ME. I'M
THERE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE A VOICE,
WHO CAN'T STAND UP FOR
THEMSELVES, THAT'S THE PEOPLE
I'M THERE TO SERVE. SO YOU HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND WHO YOUR
CONSTITUENCY IS. YOU NEED TO
HAVE A CONSTITUENCY.
YOU MUST BE HUMBLE AND HE SAID
TO ME, NDABA, YOU MUST NEVER
DRIVE A JAGUAR, BECAUSE THEN
PEOPLE KNOW HOW MUCH MONEY YOU
HAVE.
AND THEN I THOUGHT TO MYSELF,
BUT,
GRAD DAD, YOU USED TO DRIVE A
MERCEDES BENZ. OKAY, OKAY. BUT
I'LL TAKE IT ON THE CHIN. I'LL
TAKE IT ON THE CHIN.  BUT, OF
COURSE, I THINK HE WAS VERY
SERIOUS AT THE SAME TIME.
YOU KNOW? DISCIPLINE IS VERY
IMPORTANT. AND HE WAS ONE OF THE
MOST DISCIPLINED PERSONS I'VE
EVER MET.
YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY AS HE WAS
GETTING OLDER, HE WOULD GET SICK
FROM TIME TO TIME.
AND THE DOCTOR WOULD SAY, YOU
MUST EAT
MORE TOMATOES AND YOU'D TELMA MA
KOLI, EVERY MORNING, I WANT YOU
TO SLICE UP TWO TOMATOES. THIN A
COUPLE OF MONTHS LATER, HE WOULD
SAY, NO, YOU MUST EAT LESS
TOMATOES. AND THEN HE WOULD SAY,
MAKE SURE THERE ARE NO MORE
TOMATOES. NOW I WANT APPLES.
HE WOULD DO IT RELIGIOUSLY EVERY
DAY. YOU KNOW?
DISCIPLINE. INTEGRITY, VERY
IMPORTANT.  IF YOU TELL YOUR
FRIEND, HEY, LET'S MEET AT THE
LIBRARY AT 2:00, BE THERE AT
2:00.OFF KNOW? HE'D SAY, LISTEN,
I'M GOING TO SEND YOU THAT
E-MAIL LATER TONIGHT, SEND THAT
E-MAIL LATER TONIGHT. THAT'S
INTEGRITY ON B A VERY BASIC
LEVEL, YOU KNOW?  BUT IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT. IT GOES A LONG WAY.
BUT MANDIBA? WHAT CAN I SAY
ABOUT MANDIBA?
HE TAUGHT ME THAW LOVE IS
STRONGER THAN HATE.
BECAUSE LOVE COMES MUCH MORE
NATURAL TO THE HUMAN CONDITION
THAN HATE. IF A PERSON CAN BE
TAUGHT TO HATE, THEY CAN BE
TAUGHT TO LOVE.
THAT'S OUR THEME FOR CELEBRATING
MANDELA FOR 100 YEARS, LOVE AND
UNITY. BECAUSE THROUGH LOVE AND
UNITY, THERE'S NOTHING THAT WE
CANNOT ACHIEVE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE A CHANCE
TO MAKE HIM PROUD.
AND I THINK HE CONTINUES TO BE
PROUD.
>> THANK YOU, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
>> HAYDEN: SO WE HAVE TIME FOR A
FEW QUESTIONS, I UNDERSTAND.
AND THERE IS A MICROPHONE. I
HOPE.
AND HERE ARE SOME PEOPLE.
AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO AND OF
COURSE
THE BOOK IS AVAILABLE, AND
THERE'S A YOUNG MAN RIGHT HERE
--
>> MANDELA: RIGHT HERE.
>> HAYDEN: RIGHT IN FRONT.
LOOKS LIKE HE'S ABOUT THE AGE
WHEN YOU
WERE TRYING TO SNEAK OUT.
SURE, INTRODUCE YOURSELF.
>> MY NAME IS JOSHUA.
I'M A RISING SOPHOMORE AT MOORE
HOUSE COLLEGE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> I'M A CINEMA, TELEVISION, AND
EMERGING MEDIA STUDIES MAJOR AND
A JOURNALISM MINOR. I'M FROM
COLUMBIA, MARYLAND SO I GUESS
I'M COMMUTING. I'M A JUNIOR
FELLOW AT THE LIBRARY OF
COMMERCE. I WORK IN THE PHOTOS
AND PRINTS COLLECTION.
YEAH, I'M AN INTERN HERE. SORRY.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS YOU SAY
THAT YOU SEE THE BEST AND THE
WORST, SOCIOECONOMICALLY AND ON
THE EDUCATIONAL
LEVEL OF THE PUBLIC IN AFRICA,
HOW COULD THAT TRANSLATE TO
HELPING THE BLACK COMMUNITY IN
AMERICA?
>> MANDELA: WELL, WHAT THAT SAYS
IS LIKE WHAT I SAID NOW, THROUGH
LOVE AND UNITY,
YOU KNOW, MANDIBA SAID YOU CAN
JUDGE THE SOCIETY THERE'S NO
KEENER REVELATION TO A SOCIETY'S
SOUL THAN IN THE WAY THEY TREAT
THEIR CHILDREN, RIGHT?
SO WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
DO AS
MUCH AS WE CAN TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOUNG
PEOPLE HAVE MENTORSHIP, GOOD
MENTORS.
THEY MAY NOT HAVE THE BEST
SCHOOLS, BUT WE CAN TEACH ONE OF
US SITTING IN THIS ROOM MENTOR A
YOUNG CHILD FOR ONE HOUR OR TWO
HOURS A WEEK.  THAT WILL GO A
LONG WAY.
IF YOU CAN SIT WITH THEM FOR ONE
HOUR A WEEK ON A SATURDAY,
RIGHT?
AND GO THROUGH HIS HOMEWORK AND
ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT HE
EXPERIENCED IN THAT WEEK AND
WHAT HIS CHALLENGES ARE,
THINK ABOUT THE IMPACT THAT IT
WILL HAVE IF YOU DO THAT FOR
FIVE YEARS, RIGHT?
WE CANNOT -- THESE DAYS, THE
MOST INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE ARE NO
LONGER YOUR LAWYERS OR YOUR
POLICEMEN, RIGHT? THE MOST
INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE TODAY ARE POP
STARS.
RIGHT?
YOUR MUSICIANS, YOUR ACTORS, WHO
ARE NOT NECESSARILY COGNIZANT OF
THE EFFECT THEY HAVE ON A YOUNG
KID'S MIND, RIGHT? BECAUSE THEY
ENGAGE FROM TIME TO TIME IN
NEGATIVE BEHAVIOR. AND SOME OF
THEM WILL SAY, WELL, I DIDN'T
WANT TO BE A MENTOR. I DIDN'T
CHOOSE TO BE A MENTOR. DOESN'T
MATTER IF YOU CHOSE IT OR NOT.
YOU ARE A PERSON IN AN
INFLUENTIAL PERSON, SO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND EMBRACE THAT
POSITION THAT YOU'RE IN.  RIGHT?
SO IF WE CAN TAKE TIME TO SPEND
TIME WITH THE YOUNG PERSON AND
TAKE SOME OF THE LESSONS OF
NELSON MANDELA, DON'T YOU THINK
THIS WORLD WOULD BE A BETTER
PLACE FIVE TO TEN YEARS FROM
NOW?
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> HELLO. I'M ALSO AN INTERN FOR
THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION. I'M EMILY. I'M
CURIOUS OF THE HISTORY THAT YOU
LIVED THROUGH AND YOUR
GRANDFATHER LIVED THROUGH, HAS
OFFERED ANY PERSPECTIVE ON TO
THE WAY THAT OUR NATION IS
HEADED AND DO YOU HAVE ANY
ADVICE FOR FOLKS WHO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
HUMANITY BASED ON SOME OF THE
POLITICS THAT WE ARE LIVING
THROUGH RIGHT NOW AND THE
DIRECTION THAT WE'RE HEADING IN
AS A NATION?
>> MANDELA: YES, YOU KNOW, WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT THE IMMIGRATION
ISSUE WHICH I SEE IS VERY BIG
RIGHT NOW, AND IT'S VERY SIMILAR
TO OUR COUNTRY. WE WENT THROUGH
A SIMILAR THING, BUT IN
OUR COUNTRY, WE ACTUALLY HAD
ATTACKS, THE PHOBIA OF FEAR OF
PEOPLE FROM
OUTSIDE OF YOUR COUNTRY,
FOREIGNERS, PRETTY MUCH. FEAR OF
FOREIGNERS. AND IT WAS SO BAD
THAT SOUTH AFRICANS
WERE PHYSICALLY ATTACKING
ETHIOPIANS, ZIMBABWEANS,
NIGERIANS, ETC.
THEY'RE STEALING OUR JOBS,
MESSING UP OUR ECONOMY, ETC.,
ETC.
IT'S A DAMN SHAME, IT'S A DAMN
SHAME. BECAUSE THESE ARE THE
VERY SAME PEOPLE THAT ASSISTED
YOU IN LIBERATING YOUR COUNTRY.
THESE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE WHO
BUILT THE FUNDAMENTALS AND THE
BUILDING BLOCKS OF AMERICAN
SOCIETY.  RIGHT?
[ APPLAUSE ]
SOD HOW DO WE TURN OUR BACK NOW
WE'RE
EXPERIENCING PROSPERITY AND
EXPERIENCING NEW OPPORTUNITIES
AND THE TICK NOLING BOOM AND ALL
OF THESE AMAZING NEW THINGS,
HEY, YOU BUILT OUR COUNTRY, NOW
IT'S TIME FOR YOU TO LEAVE
BECAUSE WE WANT TO ENJOY IT BY
OURSELVES, YOU UNDERSTAND? WE
NEED TO REMIND EACH OTHER WHERE
WE COME FROM.
HOW GREAT IS THIS COUNTRY BUILT.
IT'S NOT BUILT BY AMERICANS.
IT'S BUILT BY PEOPLE AROUND THE
WORLD. SO WHY ARE WE CHASTISING
OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS WHO
HELPED US GET HERE TODAY?
>> HAYDEN: WE'RE TAPING THIS
BECAUSE A
LOT OF THE STAFF MEMBERS HERE
ARE GOING BACK TO THEIR POST. IF
YOU SEE PEOPLE LEAVE, THAT'S
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
>> MANDELA: WHERE I COME FROM,
WE --  I DON'T HAVE TO INTRODUCE
MYSELF TO YOU,
BUT FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE
AUDIENCE, I,
TOO, MY NAME IS -- AND MY
SURNAME IS MANDELA, I'M FROM THE
HOUSE OF MANDELA IN UNU. I
WANTED TO AFFIRM AND CONFIRM
THAT WHAT YOU'VE INDEED WRITTEN
IN YOUR BOOK
IS TRUE AND I WANT TO THANK YOU,
NDABA, FOR THE GRAND
ARTICULATION OF OUR
CULTURE AND HOW WE EXPLAINED TO
THE
WORLD THAT THE KINGDOM IS BEING
CONFIGURED, THE CONFIGURATION OF
THE KINGDOM. SO THANK YOU, AS
THE YOUNGER BROTHER I'VE ALWAYS
LOOKED UP TO YOU. UNFORTUNATELY,
YOU DIDN'T TELL ME THAT
IN COMING TO AMERICA --
(INDISCERNIBLE)  AND I SAID TO
MYSELF, I'M GOING TO SURPRISE
HIM.
SO AS A YOUNGER BROTHER WHO'S
INSPIRED BY THE WORK YOU'RE
DOING IN CARRYING IT ON WITH THE
LEGACY OF OUR GRANDFATHER,
AND I'M LENDING TO YOU,
THEREFORE, YOU MUST NOT MAKE A
SINGLE MISTAKE, BECAUSE I'M
STEPPING AT YOUR FEET.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU.
>> FAMILY IS EVERYTHING.
>> THAT'S RIGHT. I WOULDN'T BE
HERE WITHOUT IT.
>> AWESOME. THANK YOU FOR
COMING.
THANK YOU FOR DOING THE BOOK.
MY NAME IS MONTY -- MY QUESTION
RELATES TO ZIMBABWE.
AND COMPARABLY SPEAKING, NELSON
MANDELA
WAS ONE OF THE FOUNDING FATHERS,
LIBERATORS, THAT WAS ABLE TO
EVENTUALLY
HELP WITH THE DEMOCRATIZATION
EFFORTS AS WE ARE
APPROACHING ELECTIONS IN
ZIMBABWE, JULY -- THEY ANNOUNCED
FOR JULY 30, TO BE
DOING ELECTIONS, MY QUESTION IS
REGARD
ING THE 25% OF ZIMBABWEANS WHO
CURRENTLY
DWELL IN THE BEING TOLD YOU'RE
GOING TO BE EXCLUDED FROM THE
ELECTIONS UNLESS YOU COME BACK
HOME TO VOTE.
SO MY QUESTION IS, CAN YOU SHED
SOMESOME -- SOME SUGGESTIONS OR
SOME
SUPPORT AND IF YOU COULD ALSO
TOUCH ON PAN AFRICANISM ON THIS
ONE?  THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW, I CAN'T REALLY JUDGE
ON THAT ISSUE. BECAUSE IT ALSO
DEPENDS ON THE RESOURCES OF THE
COUNTRY.  YOU KNOW?
IT'S -- IF THE COUNTRY IS POOR
AND THEY DON'T HAVE RESOURCES TO
ALLOW THE CITIZENS TO VOTE BY
REMOTE CONTROL, HOW CAN I JUDGE?
YOU KNOW?
LIKELY, SOUTH AFRICA HAS NO
RESOURCES FOR PEOPLE TO VOTE AT
THEIR EMBASSIES AROUND THE
WORLD, BUT JUST BECAUSE SOUTH
AFRICA CAN DO IT DOESN'T MEAN
EVERY NATION SHOULD DO IT OR
EVERY NATION CAN DO IT. SO IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT FOR ME TO JUDGE
IN THAT SITUATION.
YES, OBVIOUSLY, IT'S
UNFORTUNATE, YOU KNOW.
YOU WANT AS MUCH CITIZENS TO
OBVIOUSLY BE INCLUDED IN THE
VOTING. BUT IT'S DIFFICULT.  YOU
KNOW? IT'S VERY DIFFICULT. YOU
CAN ONLY B HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
CARRY THE EMBASSIES AND GET
THOSE VOTES BACK TO THE
COUNTRIES. YOU KNOW? WHO CAN
JUDGE THEM FOR THAT? WE CAN'T
REALLY JUDGE THEM. SO, IF THE
ONLY WAY TO TELL PEOPLE TO COME
HOME AND VOTE, HOW CAN WE -- WE
CAN'T JUDGE THEM FOR THAT.
THERE'S NOTHING WE CAN DO.
BUT, AS FAR AS PAN AFRICANISM IS
CONCERNED, I BELIEVE THAT
LIBERATION OF SOUTH AFRICA COULD
NOT HAVE BEEN ACHIEVED WITHOUT
THE SUPPORT OF OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS ACROSS THE CONTINENTS AS
YOU KNOW.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE ZIMBABWE
AND
SWATSLAND ALL THE WAY UP TO
NIGERIA, ETHIOPIA, YOU NAME IT,
MALI, ETC.
SO, FOR ME, WE NEED SOMEHOW,
SOME WAY,
THROUGH THE
INDEPENDENT JOURNEY AND THE POST
COLONIAL AREA, WE LOST THAT PAN
AFRICANISM THAT WE ONCE HAD. WE
LOST THE UNITY AND SOLIDARITY
THAT WE ONCE HAD. IT NEEDS TO BE
REUNITED. AND IN OUR CONTINENT,
WE'RE TRADING MORE WITH THE WEST
AND THE EAST THAN WE ARE TRADING
WITH EACH OTHER, WHICH HAS NEVER
HAPPENED BEFORE.
WE NEED TO REIGNITE THAT BECAUSE
IF WE
DO NOT UNITE, AND REIGNITE THE
SPIRIT OF SOLIDARITY AMONGST
AFRICANS ON THE
CONTINENT FIRST AND FOREMOST, WE
SHALL NEVER REALIZE OUR ROAD TO
INDEPENDENCE. WE SHALL NEVER
REALIZE OUR DREAM TO CREATE A
PROSPEROUS AND INDEPENDENT
CONTINENT OF AFRICA.
THAT IS REALLY THE KEY TO US
ACHIEVING OUR GOALS AND MAKING
SURE OUR DREAMS COME TO
FRUITION.
SO, IN THE SPIRIT
OF MEN WHO WERE TRUE
VISIONARIES, AND
IN ONE OF THEIR WORDS, WE AS
AFRICANS DO NOT LOOK WEST NOR DO
WE LOOK EAST, WE LOOK FORWARD.
HUH?  THANK YOU, BROTHER.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> I'VE BEEN TOLD THAT WE HAVE
TIME FOR ONE MORE QUESTION.
SO BE WE HAVE A PERSON HERE.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, MY NAME IS
WAYNE CONNOR. I'M AN EMPLOYEE
HERE AT THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
I WORK IN THE OFFICE OF GENERAL
COUNSEL. MY QUESTION IS FOR --
FOR SOMEONE WHO HAS OBVIOUSLY
BEEN INSPIRED BY A GREAT LEADER
AND WHO IS
CURRENTLY A GREAT ADVOCATE FOR
MANY CAUSES, HOW COULD -- DO YOU
HAVE ANY ADVICE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
LIKE MYSELF OR OTHERS WHO MIGHT
BE IN THE ROOM ON HOW WE CAN
BETTER, YOU KNOW, BECOME A VOICE
AND BECOME AN INFLUENCER OF
CHANGE WITHIN OUR OWN
COMMUNITIES AND WHAT ARE SOME OF
THE TOOLS THAT WE CAN SEEK OUT
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO BE BETTER
AT THAT IN?
>> MANDELA: YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE
TO CHOOSE A CAUSE THAT YOU CARE
ABOUT, THAT YOU'RE PASSIONATE
ABOUT. IT'S LIKE BUSINESS. WHERE
YOU BECOME AN ENTREPRENEUR.
YOU CANNOT BE A SUCCESSFUL
ENTREPRENEUR IF YOU'RE NOT
PASSIONATE ABOUT THAT BUSINESS.
BECAUSE ALONG THE WAY, YOU WILL
COME ACROSS HURDLES, PEOPLE WHO
DON'T BELIEVE YOU, AND PEOPLE
WHO THINK YOU CAN'T DO IT.
RIGHT?
SO YOU NEED TO HAVE A  CAUSE
THAT YOU'RE VERY PASSIONATE
ABOUT. THAT WILL MAKE SURE THAT
YOU DON'T GIVE UP.
BECAUSE PEOPLE GIVE UP SOMETIMES
TOO QUICKLY.  YOU KNOW? FOR
VARIOUS AMOUNTS OF REASONS.
NOW, YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU SURROUND YOURSELF BY PEOPLE
WHO CARE FOR YOU AND BELIEVE IN
YOU.
YOU NEED TO HAVE A MENTOR.
EVERYBODY NEEDS A MENTOR, NO
MATTER HOW OLD YOU ARE, NO
MATTER HOW SUCCESSFUL YOU ARE,
EVERYBODY NEEDS A MENTOR.
AND, YOU NEED TO THEN UNDERSTAND
THE PEOPLE OF A CAUSE THAT
YOU'RE CHAMPIONING, WHAT THEIR
CHALLENGES ARE. YOU CANNOT
CHAMPION A CAUSE IF YOU HAVE NOT
TALKED TO THE PEOPLE THAT IT
AFFECTS THE MOST.
OTHERWISE, YOU ARE JUST SHOOTING
IN THE HEAD, RIGHT? YOU NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THAT CONSTITUENCY
THAT YOU'RE SERVING.
AND MAKE SURE THE CONCERN
YOURSELF WITH THE RIGHT PEOPLE.
AND OFTEN THAT SUPPORTS AT HOME.
THAT SUPPORT STARTS WITHIN YOUR
OWN IMMEDIATE NETWORK. AND IF
YOU CAN'T GET SUPPORT FROM YOUR
FAMILY MEMBERS AND YOUR FRIENDS
AND YOUR OWN IMMEDIATE NETWORK,
THEN, MY FRIEND, I THINK YOU
NEED TO CHANGE YOUR COURSE.
BECAUSE CLEARLY, THEY DON'T
BELIEVE YOU.
AND IF THEY DON'T BELIEVE YOU,
THEN I DON'T KNOW WHERE YOU'RE
GOING TO GET YOUR SUPPORT.
SO FIRST -- THE FIRST THING IS,
DO I REALLY CARE ABOUT THIS
THING AM I TRYING TO PUSH? AM I
IN TOUCH WITH THE PEOPLE THAT
I'M TRYING TO HELP, TRYING TO
GIVE A VOICE, TRYING TO GET A
LAW PASSED, OR AN ACTION -- YOU
KNOW, DONE, OR WHATEVER THE CASE
MAY BE. YOU KNOW? YOU NEED TO BE
IMPRESSED WITH THOSE PEOPLE.
AND HAVE A MENTOR AND A SUPPORT
BASE. BASICALLY.
AND THAT IS REALLY THE FIRST
STEPS OF
MAKING SURE THAT YOU ARE ABLE TO
SERVE
THE OBJECTIVE THAT YOU SET OUT
FOR YOURSELF DON'T DO IT BECAUSE
THE GIRL YOU LIKE SAID YOU
SHOULD DO IT. OR YOU DO IT
BECAUSE YOUR PARENTS FORCE YOU
TO DO IT. DO IT BECAUSE YOU
YOURSELF CARE AND ARE PASSIONATE
ABOUT THAT CAUSE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> HAYDEN: WE ALL THANK YOU FOR
SHARING THE LIFE LESSONS YOU
LEARNED FROM YOUR GRANDFATHER
AND SHARING THEM WITH ALL OF US.
AND I AM NEVER RECOMMEND A BOOK
BECAUSE OF WHAT I DO.
BUT IF YOU HAPPEN TO HAVE A
CHANCE TO READ WHAT YOU HAVE
LEARNED AND READ THIS
BOOK, I THINK YOU WOULD BE IN
TOUCH, NOT ONLY WITH YOUR
GRANDFATHER, BUT WITH YOU.
>> MANDELA: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> HAYDEN: THANK YOU.
7 C1